hello and welcome to this video playing
not Larson yeah I go for London system
for a change I think I do quite quite
okay with with this opening you got
played occasionally it done it won't
hurt so g6 okay yeah maybe this one
preventing Bishop a 6 for the moment
maybe you want to go Reggie you form
that seems like a possible way of
playing at drop this back yes how do i
how do i play in this position I mean
it's not my usual kind of opening
because the blends are not that
straightforward hmm not sure black seems
very solid anyway maybe before maybe I
can provoke something there now very
quickly decided that he wants to take
Adam ok I was a bit more concerned about
see form here I might be able to do
something on the queenside yeah ok does
he want to go 'if I've possible hmm
definitely possible hmm
I would like to double
'if I've tx9 tx9 Roxy one is what I'm
thinking we goes back yeah but you
cannot what is he doing now he cannot
play rook c8 now blunders the night on
be eight so not quite sure what the
point is here okay this you can
definitely play is rook c8 now possible
Neal I guess it is so what to do I can
bring the Queen to see one but it
doesn't help much
hmm ok oopsie 8 it's pretty much
impossible to prevent I mean I'll still
do that I think I'll go with the Queen
over here but yeah solidly defended
public so we'll do I have some kind of
idea what is this his idea Queen the
eighth Quincy ADA to trade even more
maybe b5 try a night see form but then I
have Quincy five okay this is important
b5 is nonsense I can also take the six
mp5 ok b5 doesn't make any sense but
Quincy 8 is not a threat I can take the
night so what to do gaining space is
probably one way prevent knight c6 and
stuff no it's still a bit more
comfortable for me he has some issues
with these pieces they are very active
so
I have at least some ideas while black
has pretty much nothing that you can do
you wants to go to g7 that seems ok I
mean that I have 95 ah this is the idea
ok for Quincy 8 hmm yeah it's a way to
prevent that all together Quincy 8 takes
Bishop cheeks hmm and not completely huh
not completely so um anything else that
I can do what about the immediate a 5
a-5 i get i get all the way to 86 and he
cannot move much let's do it let's talk
over too long maybe
sure if played that a bit quicker bit
more quickly I think is a bit a little
bit j better in terms of Grandma okay um
I can also take b6 and see if I can
attack that pawn but I don't think this
is yeah this is so i can just do that
how stupid is that I didn't think about
that at all Wow ok he cannot take it an
SBA does hanging so this is not a huge
issue so got that one in so night a for
something that I would love to play
mm-hmm nightie for take on b6 this would
be extremely cool to get in but how do I
get down via b2y a d1 time morning ma'am
ok I'm going to bring the King up first
ok this is this is easy this he has an
idea he wants to go night to see seven
ok
chick chick how you can go he can go to
before here this is the thing it's a big
problem that I didn't didn't see before
i shoot losing this game is really
really frustrating as it was so one
sided not sure why he didn't play rookie
officially one and how he sees it
yeah it's very simple this is the thing
it's very simple to win frustrating okay
I just have to play it more precisely
and I think I'm quite easily getting a
very strong position probably wrongly
timed yeah I'm still fighting but Jack
was black black should win the way he
plays it i might have chances Jack I
have learned at age five check okay yep
anyway I don't know yeah that was step
us
yeah this is force training I mean
around here um I think I should yeah I
should never lose of course it's it is
completely completely boxed in yeah yeah
I can also keep the Queen's of course
yeah I don't know yeah yes this somehow
he managed to regroup this 97 I one day
I probably have to round here okay I'm
not have much time but I just have to be
more precise here yeah here this night
over to see seven is ok probably for him
it's be five is vulnerable and maybe I
should keep the Queen's on
yeah it's very likely better and T I'm
not that Judge down on down on the clock
and I spent here from here spent I spent
time let's be five really gets
vulnerable i also didn't see that he
cannot take it directly I was only
thinking about I'm hidden getting that
night away from that bloody square but
this is of course better so probably I
should keep the Queen's on yeah
something like this for example I mean
yeah this position is just terrible for
black it's just it's just bad with all
those all those pieces and he has no
room whatsoever hm and yeah it gets very
difficult it's very difficult probably
probably not possible to hold in the
long run at least get this and this is
given by the engine King be one that's
still quite kind of tough but ok 20
seconds is not and not great may be here
still have chances to hold it even
though it doesn't look good yeah now
this will probably go down in the long
run now after you have to keep Queens on
check not even sure why I didn't
consider that it's really a lot better
hmm
and maybe I thought it's simpler to play
with with Queens off i don't know but
it's clearly better to not trade queens
go here or d2 or it doesn't really
matter where that gives that that puts a
lot more pressure on black as it as he
has less space and the Queen doesn't
really have good squares stuff like that
it's not doing much yeah it's
frustrating anyway thanks for watching